and i said so i just need you to tell me
and if you tell me the truth we can
help and he wasn't able to do that
meghan markle is opening up about the
struggles within her own family
her parents were incredible
so i know they must be proud now i know
my dad
is there was such an obsession
about anything in my world including
tracking down my parents and i did
everything i could to protect both of
them
in that media frenzy these new moments
came courtesy of oprah winfrey on monday
who stopped by cbs this morning to
reflect on her bombshell interview with
megan and harry
all i will say is clearly this
interview this dynamite interview
will have tested family relationships
apparently the two-hour broadcast still
left some moments on the cutting room
floor
the iconic talk show host brought
previously unaired clips
from her time with the duke and duchess
of sussex i'm just trying to decide if
i'm comfortable even talking about that
one of the topics megan's estranged
father thomas markle
who was scheduled to be interviewed on
good morning britain on tuesday did it
feel like betrayal when you found out
your father
was working with the tabloids megan
detailed the struggles leading up to her
2018 wedding
when thomas began speaking to the press
we called my dad and i asked him
and he said no absolutely not
i said you know the the institution
has never intervened for anything for us
but they can try to go in and kill this
story
but if they do this once we're not going
to be able to use that same leverage to
protect our own kids one day
and i said so i just need you to tell me
and if you tell me the truth we can
help megan recalled how her mother doria
ragland had similarly been hunted by the
press
but has continuously rejected offers
from the media
everyone has accountability look they've
hunted my mom down
right and she didn't speak at the time
i've never heard her say
a word she's remained in silent dignity
for four years
watching me go through this and the
family talk didn't stop there
it was great fun being big sister and
she was delightful
with megan touching upon her half-sister
samantha markle
who wrote a tell-all book that was
published last month
i mean the last time i saw her must have
been at least
18 19 years ago i think it'd be very
hard to tell all when you don't know me
and i i mean it's
this is a very different situation than
my dad right when you talk about
betrayal betrayal comes from someone
that you have a relationship with
right i i don't feel comfortable talking
about people that i really don't know
so what's next for the couple etsy asked
royal expert katie nicholl for some
insight
can harry ever return home can he ever
go back home
well i think the big question everyone
is going to be asking themselves once
they've
sat down and absorbed all of this is is
there any coming back from this
harry has made it very clear that he
hopes that these family risks
can be repaired i can't see the couple
standing on the buckingham palace
balcony for the queen's trooping anytime
soon and given the storm
and the controversy the hurt and the
upset that this interview has
ultimately caused um i think many
bridges are going to
need to be repaired before that moment